numerous nationwide polls have shown
that our president our fearless leader
Donald Trump has the lowest approval
rating of any new president in US
history okay we have a graphic that
we're going to put up here for you and
it shows the very early trend line of
disapproval for Donald Trump which has
been trickling up not improving
certainly the way that Trump is claimed
Trump's approval would after he took
office this weekend Gallup poll had
Trump at forty-two percent approval last
week CBS poll at forty percent last week
CNN poll at forty four percent compare
Donald Trump's early approval at this
point in his administration to pass
presidents and we'll put that up for you
next and you'll see here that Donald
Trump at forty four percent at this
point in his presidency is just barely
more than half of President Obama
seventy-six percent approval at this
point in his presidency george w bush
had fifty eight percent approval at this
point clinton very similar at 59 bush
one very similar at 57 ronald reagan the
second lowest approval at this point in
his presidency at 51% and you can go
back and see the numbers for carter and
Nixon at 66 and fifty-nine percent
respectively so Donald Trump compared to
other presidents really not doing well
at this particular point in time we also
have a PPP poll last week this is just
amazing which found that most Americans
wish President Obama was still president
of the United States and Donald Trump
started the hysterical tweeting
obviously at what let's put the tweetup
what time was this Pat 401 a.m. in the
morning it every single dime it's just
very very bizarre saying any negative
poles are fake news just like the CNN
ABC NBC polls in the election first of
all most of the poles during the
election weren't wrong this like woods
brexit this is a completely debunked
mean that the polls were way off most of
the poles during the election weren't
wrong they predicted Hillary clean
would win the popular vote by a few
points which she did I will remind you
and ultimately trumped one electoral e
because of seventy seven thousand votes
in three states the polls were basically
right within their stated margin of
errors and and spot-on when it comes to
the popular vote and they were also
portraying toss-ups in North Carolina
and Florida as that turned out to be I
just don't think there was significant
polling in Michigan and Wisconsin in
Pennsylvania because that's just
considered a democratic stronghold yeah
less polling in those states so number
one Trump is just wrong about the
narrative East crafting here that just
because we couldn't trust the election
polls we can't trust these polls the
election polls were actually pretty good
but more importantly Trump is telling
Americans to ignore scientific polls
because they make him look bad this is
mind blowing anti-intellectual
authoritarian delusional lot nonsense
and I want to follow up by putting that
tweet from Donald Trump back up he also
ended the tweet by saying sorry people
want border security and extreme betting
this also isn't true according to last
week's CNN lrc poll which was not fake
most Americans don't want a border wall
by a twenty-two percent margin a
plurality of Americans are against the
Muslim immigration band and think that
it actually makes the us less safe from
terrorism that it harms American values
every aspect of this tweet from Donald
Trump is effectively wrong and Trump
said last October when we do badly I
don't talk about the polls when we're
doing well I talk about the polls I
think we do we have that tweet Pat from
Donald Trump when we do badly I don't
talk about the polls when we're doing
well I do talk about the polls and
clearly right now because many people
are talking about the polls and they're
not good from attempting to just dismiss
them as fake is this the sort of
alternative facts alternate reality of
the next four years i think it probably
is kind of like when Trump lost the
popular vote and of course the election
had to have been rigged with three to
five million undocumented immigrant
voters
this is the world we live in right now
and if it weren't for the fact that
millions of Trumpets believe it I'd be
way less worried about it I think this
is the new paradigm now there's no
consistency anymore and I mean I
remember back to the days where Trump
would attend these rallies and half of
the rally was just reading off poll
numbers where he was ahead in each
single one of them he literally said
once I started to lose I don't believe
that I'm anymore Trump also pushing back
against the narrative that he doesn't
know or isn't fully in charge of what's
going on in his administration he
tweeted later yesterday morning no
longer at 4am but now at 40 7am which
becomes a much more reasonable time to
be tweeting quote I call my own shots
large largely based on an accumulation
of data and everyone knows it some fake
news media in order to marginalize cama
lies once again a completely
unintelligible sentence from Donald
Trump and I guess what he's saying there
is he's in charge and fake news blah
blah blah blah blah fake news is now a
completely overused buzzword remember
regressive left the tremor aggressive
left was sort of started to be used to
point to a liberal ideas or views
espoused by someone who is putative Lee
on the left and then regressive left
just became used by the right to point
through anything that they don't like
right so regressive left completely lost
its meaning fake news deliberately was
or referred deliberately to the
satirical or fake news sites during the
election which would put out completely
bogus stories Hillary Clinton arrest
warrant issued for Hillary Clinton stuff
like that and now and it's validated by
the administration fake news is being
used to refer to any news where you
don't like what they say it's definitely
one of those buzzwords it's kind of like
the song of the summer that gets played
over and over again and then just kind
of no one's interested anymore and moves
on yeah and I think it's going to be
time to move on from fake news and if
you look at our YouTube channel and I
know you do Pat it's riddled with
comments people just think this is fake
news because they just don't like it
they're trumpets and they don't like
what we're reporting and now they call
it fake news and it's deliberately meant
to confuse people because fake news had
one meaning and now it's just if I don't
like the news it's fake
send me your thoughts on this i'm on
twitter at d pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show today's
show is brought to you by godaddy where
you can buy your own domain name build a
website or use any of Go Daddy's
business tools you can save thirty
percent at try godaddy.com slash david
go daddy has actually been the official
host of the david pakman show website
for many many many years the 24 7
customer support has been a very good
thing for us I've called them at really
odd times when we've had website issues
and they are always available they are
the largest domain registrar and whether
you have a new idea you're an
established business you're creating a
personal website or moving your large
enterprise site over to godaddy they can
do it all 13 million customers try it
and get thirty percent off at try
godaddy.com slash david